[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
point de vue où l'on débat de
l'actualité point de vue ou vos
commentaires vos questions sont toujours
les bienvenus l'actualité c'est le
verdict attendu dans le procès verra
après cinq semaines d'audiences
l'avocate générale a réclamé la
perpétuité sera t-elle suivi en espagne
et dans un tout autre contexte c'est en
prison en détention provisoire ont été
placés les indépendantistes catalans
jugé par madrid carlos guzman est lui
resté prudemment à bruxelles mais un
mandat d'arrêt devrait bientôt être
lancée contre lui
où en est la république en marche c'est
ce soir que sont closes les candidatures
pour sa direction en réalité christophe
castaner en deviendra on le sait le
patron le 18 novembre
mais le patron d'une coquille vide on va
en parler
la légion d'honneur devrait-elle subir
une cure d'amaigrissement plus de
décoration tenu à l'usure plus de
copinage
comme l'a annoncé le figaro emmanuel
macron veut réduire fortement le nombre
de récits pente hier olivier duhamel
bonjour 1,7 juristes politologues vous
êtes l'auteur de maquereaux et en même
temps avec laurent bigorgne et alice
beaudry livre paru récemment chez plon
et vous retrouvez votre complice ou
adversaires sur ce plateau alexis brézet
bonjour ali le directeur des rédactions
du figaro
à côté de vous nous avons le plaisir de
retrouver mathieu aron directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de l'obs bonjour mathieu
bonsoir l'ops dont la couverture est
consacré cette semaine aux prêts
adolescente à quoi pensent les petites
filles c'est votre votre titre et nous
sommes également heureux de vous
accueillir emmanuel rivière vous êtes
directeur de l'institut kantar public
kantar qui livrent au figaro magazine
cette semaine un sondage sur la
popularité des manuels macron vouloir
dire est qu'il en est bonjour alors le
procès meira on attend donc d'un instant
à l'autre le verdict la perpétuité a été
requise contre le frère du terrorisme de
montauban et de toulouse
quel est le bilan de ces cinq semaines
d'audience on va en parler avant on
écoute l'un des avocats des parties
civiles maître patrick klugman avocat de
monsieur sandler ce monsieur qui a perdu
son fils et deux de ses petits enfants
dans l'attentât contre l'école juive de
toulouse c'était ce matin sur europe 1
il n'y a pas d'exemple en justice
l'exemple en justice et de juges
les hommes que nous avons un juge et
avec les faits qu'ils ont commis et leur
responsabilité propre et nous pensons
que la responsabilité d'abdel kader
meira est accablante parce que vous
enlevez celui là son petit frère
n'existe pas il n'existe peut-être
il exploite être comme un délinquant
certainement pas comment salafistes et
certainement pas comme un assassin au
lycée duhamel il ya un long procès cinq
semaines d'audiences effectivement des
magistrats professionnels
la justice peut-elle s'appliquer
normalement dans les affaires
terroristes parce que la justice peut
jamais s'appliquer normalement quand un
fait divers au sens le plus large du
terme à a eu une dimension spectaculaire
a bouleversé l'opinion je suis pas
certain labrecque moi je ne vais pas
faire le procès du procès je ne peux pas
me prononcer sur un procès auquel je
n'ai pas assisté est d'ailleurs
peut-être même pas assez du tout les
comptes rendus là la vraie question la
question centrale c'est la question de
la preuve est ce qu'il ya une preuve
suffisante pour établir la complicité si
oui il doit être condamné
est ce qu'il n'ya pas de preuves
suffisantes sinon il ne doit pas l'être
tout le reste n'est que littérature pour
les fuyards ont sur ce sujet je vais je
partage ce sentiment avec quand même un
risque de trouble s'il n'était pas
condamné
j'entends par là que au début du procès
lorsqu'il ya eu lieu l'instruction ça
paraissait jouer ça paraissait évident
tout le monde pensait qu'il y avait des
éléments nécessaires et suffisants pour
effectivement le condamner s'il s'avère
que à l'issue de ce procès que moi non
plus je n'ai pas suivi et dont j'ai lu
juste quelques comptes rendus il y a un
problème de preuve
et si jamais il n'était pas condamné
alors l'opinion publique on a du mal à
comprendre même si justice est bonne
justice aura probablement été faites et
puis au delà de ça il ya toute la
problématique qui existe dans ces
affaires de terrorisme
soyez des faits des preuves matérielles
qu'on peut mettre en avant
soit on est plutôt dans l'ordre de l'
influence intellectuelle et là ça
devient beaucoup plus compliqué donc
c'est aussi cette question que pose ce
qu'on sait quoi alexis lakic un
acquittement serait totalement
incompréhensible opinion sur moi alors
je veux dire les mêmes propre prendre
les mêmes précautions d'usagé mais qui
sont réelles canton c'est très difficile
de juger une affaire de toute façon
quand on n'a pas assisté
au procès même si on assiste et non pas
forcément stéphane durand souffland qui
pour le filet ont fait d'excellents
papier tous les jours même lui qui
insistait ben c'est difficile de se
faire une opinion
donc il ya le cas d'abdelkader mairat
qui est pas ça parce qu'on dit il il est
complice ou n'est pas complice mais
est-ce qu'il savait ce qui allait faire
son frère si le s'il le savait il peut
la voir suez ne pas l'avoir empêché
c'est une chose
il peut la voir s'ils n'ont pas l'avoir
empêché il avoir encouragé il peut
l'avoir su ne pas l'avoir empêché ne pas
l'avoir encouragée et y avoir plus ou
moins prêter la main note bon donc ça il
ya comme une gradation enfin c'est pas
une porte ouverte ou fermée il peut y
avoir d'aidé entre deux dons qu'il ya le
cas d'abdel kader mira qui est très
compliqué ça on verra ce que nous en
disent les juges
après il ya ce que nous apprend comme le
ce procès il apprend des choses où il
confirme ainsi un nombre de choses sur
sur l'île sur l'état de la société
française aujourd'hui où il ya cinq ans
qui sont quand même frappante
conques et notamment cette espèce de
bouillon de culture qu'il ya dans
certains quartiers en france on place le
quartier des izards à côté de toulouse
2-2 haine absolue de l'est de la france
des juifs des occidentaux de d'allers
retours entre la france et la syrie on y
va on revient il ya des maîtres à penser
il ya le gourou les fameux groupe darty
gâte là qui est un ancien syrien qui
corrèle qui vident en ariège on va le
voir
il revient il envoie un de ces gars qui
arrive en mercedes avec sa longue barbe
enfin il ya dessus tout en même temps
une famille mairat qui elle même n'est
pas uniforme
il ya dans la filiale en autriche le
frère aîné qui lui-même est brouillé
avec ce abdelkader qui d'ailleurs a
voulu le poignarder une des deux soeurs
également est une des deux soeurs qui
est devenu je crois coiffeuse et qui est
totalement intégrée mais met ça face à
cette réalité là elle est comme
absolument frappante est saisissante il
ya un autre à si vous permettez sur pour
lequel il faut regarder le jugement de
très près c'est celui de feta malki
c'est à dire celui qui a fourni les
arbres alors ce que j'ai cru comprendre
mais encore une fois je parle avec
précaution n'étant pas c'est que il
n'est pas entré qui n'est pas prouvée du
ou qu'ils savaient que ces armes
allaient participer à un projet
terroriste
si on condamnait quelqu'un de complicité
de terrorisme alors qu'il a vendu des
armes sans savoir que c'était dans un
projet terroriste là du point de vue de
la justice ce serait très volontiers
emmanuel rivière où c'est effectivement
très suivis par les français ce procès
ça c'est évidemment quelque chose qui va
attirer l'attention et je rejoins chacun
de vous trois c'est que le tribunal de
l'opinion n'est vraiment pas le bon
tribunal pour rendre une bonne justice
mais il faut avoir en tête le fait qu'on
a en fait pris sable depuis les cinq ans
qui sont écoulés depuis la fermera elle
est revisitée avec une tout autre
perspective
il ya cinq ans et demi en avait un peu
tous acheté l'idée du loup isolés y
compris parce que c'était une thèse
rassurante par rapport à l'abomination
17 alors que on regarde maintenant avec
une autre perspective ces questions et
de comportement avec l'idée
qu'effectivement il ya un halo de
propagation d'idées d'encouragement dans
laquelle on a envie de trouver des
coupables et d'interrompre cette logique
d'un flux ans donc je pense
qu'effectivement risque d'y avoir un
certain trouble
si la justice qui est rendue ne
condamnait pas les agréments pour dire
ce que vous disiez l'instant ce qui est
assez frappant moi je trouve que ce
qu'est ce qui transparaît de ce que
disent les audiences et des comptes
rendus d'audience qui sont faits dans la
presse à la radio la télévision
c'est ce climat de haine absolue dans
cette famille il ya comme une haine de
soi même dans cette famille qui est
terrifiante et c'était haine de soi se
transforme dans une veine des autres
dans la haine du juif dans la haine de
tout ce qui est ça je trouve que ce
ressort il apparaît bien dans ce procès
au-delà des faits qui seront ou pas
établi mais cet ultra violence entre les
membres de cette famille qui rejaillit
sur après sur cette forme
d'antisémitisme et on sait bien que
l'antisémitisme trouve aussi cette forme
là et ça je trouve que ça s'est
maintenue bien joué 66 et l'enracinement
profond dans cette semaine parce que le
tribunal nous dira si abdelkader et plus
nous non complice dans quelle mesure il
est mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
un islamiste
absolument convaincu qui tout au long du
procès n'a pas un mot de regret qui est
absolument enfermé dans dance dans sa
réalité qui dit vous autres les français
vous avez vous à l'heure nous nous avons
les nôtres qui donc est dans une espèce
de violence absolue mais on peut pas
condamner poncet je ne dis pas qu'on
peut condamner pour ça mais je dis que
la réalité de cet homme là alors elle
seule elle est effrayante
voilà c'est un élément de personnalités
sur vos assistants compte sur l'opinion
si je me trompe pas mais on va pas vous
tromper
il ya 40 ou 50 ans il est arrivé pendant
des procès ou juste après un procès en
face des sondages très très choquant sur
le thème faut-il condamner à mort foutu
l'exécuter buffet bontems que ça
aujourd'hui on fait plus simple on parle
très souvent de la dégradation de sophie
légal de la de faire un sondage effet un
sondage en tout cas en cours de procès
sur la fondation gérant en tout cas nous
pendant que figuration questionner la
maison on suppose donc pose jamais la
question du jour sur ma chatte est
coupable il me semble est souvent
payante les médias les réseaux sociaux
maintenant on fait n'importe quoi qui
était fermée hier sur lequel l inverse
progressant de l'accident n'ont pas du
tout mon procès de christian ranucci la
sphère du coup les verts rouges accusés
d'avoir créé une petite fille la presse
avait organisé plusieurs plusieurs
sondages plusieurs projets et il ya eu
un sondage de l'époque du parisien qui
indexe 90% des français étaient pour
absolument pour la peine de mort pour
les assassins d'enfants et ce sondage
est paru deux jours avant le début de ce
processeur sale affaire meira c'est vrai
c'était aussi le début on a reparlé de
la montée de l'antisémitisme à ce moment
et ce soir on va écouter maître francis
szpiner l'avocat de la famille d'ilan
halimi et qui s'étonne que les récents
propos d'un proviseur de marseille
dénonçant l'antisémitisme n'est pas et
créé plus de remous oui l'antisémitisme
n'a cessé de progresser et il n'a cessé
de progresser dans une indifférence
générale dernièrement un proviseur
monsieur avait fait un livre
et il explique à marseille par exemple
il ne peut pas scolarisés dans son
collège un enfant parce qu'il est juif
en d'autres temps cela aurait provoqué
une révolte est un scandale dans la
société française
et finalement ces révélations dont les
bulles personnes il y à une banalisation
uhsa cocu manceau fait qu'une partie de
la population a fait sécession de la
république et la raison francis szpiner
on a sous-estimé la menthe à
l'antisémitisme
en 2012 il la fermera sa puce produire
je pense que depuis les choses ont un
peu bougé quand même été à des voix qui
se sont élevées qui ont donc plus en
plus dit qu'il y avait un antisémitisme
à l'extrême gauche qui avait un
antisémitisme dans certains secteurs de
la population que l'antisionisme et est
le paravent commode de l'antisémitisme
c'était pas vrai en effet probablement
il ya une dizaine d'années même c'est
vrai qu'on le disait moi mais ce qui
m'étonne c'est qu'on continue jour
toujours jolie parler d'une nouvel
antisémitisme d'un nouvel an redécouvre
intimement un nouvel antisémitisme
qu'avec l'air de s'ébaubir que quelque
chose d'absolument nouveau qu'on aura un
bon ça va maintenant ça fait quand même
vingt ans que ça dure et nous dire via
un antisémitisme je parle du monde qui
vit un antisémitisme du quotidien c'est
pas qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
d'anti civis du quotidien c'est pas le
quotidien qui est antisémite ce sont des
gens qui sont antisémites se sont dans
certains quartiers sont des populations
qui souvent sont musulmanes qui sont
antisémites
il ya quand même un moment il faut dire
les choses et pas toujours faire
semblant de croire faire des périphrases
pour dire qu' il ya un espèce de chose
qui s'appelle en team 10 qui flottent en
l'air et dont on ne sait pas sur qui ça
retombe
aujourd'hui on sait sur qui sur qui sur
qui ça retombe tout cas de qui ça vient
mais parce que la réalité de base et les
lacets une carte cas il ya des personnes
la plupart du temps riff qui sont
victimes d'actes d'agression parce qu'il
sent juive donc quelles que soient la
nature c'est aberrant car même si ses
mérites musulmans parce qu'il ya eu même
leurs enfants par une équipe adam lang
après il ya quelque chose qui mérite
bien le nom de nouveau même s'il n'est
pas récent c'est à dire que il ya eu ou
d'or
une séquence historique après la guerre
et jusque dans les années soixante dix
où on avait le sentiment qu'un certain
antisémitisme et historique très ancrée
était en voie de complète résorption et
un renouvellement y compris un
renouvellement très fortement ressenti
par la population la communauté juive
comme une recrudescence comme
symptomatique d'une recrudescence
mais il n'est pas effectivement hier il
date principalement la deuxième intifada
je dirai juste refoulement co op soins
au milieu des années 60 avait une
majorité de français qui disait qu'il ne
dirait pas un juif à la présidence de la
république ce qui est inconcevable
aujourd'hui mais ce qui à l'époque était
encore vrai au milieu des années 60
il n'empêche que je trouve que francis
szpiner n'a pas tort dans ce qu'il dit
c'est à dire que les souligner le fait
qu'un certain nombre de choses qui se
passent aujourd'hui nous aurait
profondément choqué il ya 15 ou 20 ans
et qu'aujourd'hui elle nous choque moins
donc elles sont acceptées qu'une fille
est une forme de banalisation est
effectivement des plusieurs sujets qui
ont été faits dans la presse ces
dernières semaines suite à l'agression
de ce couple à livry gargan agression
d'une ultra violence qui a touché un
couple de retraités à cette occasion on
a pu que constater our constater que
tout un tas de familles juives quittait
la seine saint denis ou au moins qui tu
es un certain nombre de villes de
seine-saint-denis qu'il était devenu à
peu près impossible ou qu'elle se
sentait dans l'impossibilité en tout cas
dit d'y habiter
et ça je trouve que effectivement c'est
d'une gravité absolue et peut-être qu'on
ne le souligne peut-être pas assez
encore fortement vous avez affiche grand
et je passe quelque chose qu'il ait
d'explication mais ça ne vaut pas
justification si on regarde dans la
longue distance historique il ya un
siècle
vous aviez un antisémitisme ouvert et
vous aviez l'expression politique par
beaucoup de cet antisémitisme sans que
ça gêne personne enfin ça le gêne est
évidemment tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord mais c'était possible de te
dire des dirigeants politiques des
intellectuels pouvait tenir publiquement
des propos d'une violence inouïe contre
les juifs de morale sado des repas soit
par qui vous voulez aujourd'hui c'est
inconcevable aujourd'hui même au front
national des quelqu'un dit un mot semi
antisémite il est viré vue selon
l'avionneur
et du coup commis à cet interdit qui
s'est vraiment installés au niveau
des élites dirigeantes quelle qu'elle
soit du coup on en conclut trop vite ça
va mieux que l'antisémitisme est de lui
qui se résorbe et alors qu'on a tort
c'est pas ça le même pardon et donc moi
je pense que je vais le vrai frein
levrette avancé a longtemps laissé les
catholiques
oui il ya eu dans this is catholique
avec atelier conte fait la normale mais
aujourd'hui c'est les musulmans disent
que le fait qu'on n'ose pas en parler
mais qu'il allait de cette source-là
évidemment mais le fait qu'on ne veuille
pas en parler c'est pour ne pas mettre
de l'huile sur le feu c'est ne pas
rajouter de la stigmatisation on l'a vu
très bien dans la sphère de cette dame
madame halimi ou le gars la jette par la
fenêtre la massacrer crie allah akbar et
la jette par la fenêtre il faut des
jours et des jours pour qu'on en parle
et qu'on ose se dire que peut-être c'est
un crime raciste parce qu'on veut pas le
dire parce que et on voit encore joué il
a fait un certain nombre de médias
traitent cette affaire là c'est pour
dire ne stigmatisons pas les musulmans
des musulmans c'est la même chose donc
on finit par ne plus dire la raison de
dire des mémoires à jamais dans ma
bouche
ce réflexe là qui fait que ne voulant
pas stigmatiser nous voulons pas mettre
de l'huile sur le feu on finit par ne
plus dire les choses et part se cacher
la vérité alors on a raison de ne pas
stigmatiser telle qu'il ne faut jamais
stigmatisé il n'empêche que
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre de
chiffres qui moi me hear it un peu quand
on ne cesse de comparer par exemple des
données qui sont difficilement
comparables c'est à dire ces actes qui
visent d'un côté les juive l'autre côté
les musulmans on oublie quand on parle
de ces chiffres jusque les populations
ne sont absolument pas identiques que le
nombre de jeunes visés par infiniment
plus faible que le nombre de musulmans
ni moins de juifs en france que
musulmans et donc on fait dire à ces
chiffres à peu près tout et n'importe
quoi et si on fait cette comparaison
pour dire regardez c'est à peu près
équivalent c'est justement pour ne pas
stigmatiser sauf que ce faisant on dit
des grosses conneries pour le dire un
peu crûment et en plus on fait rentrer
dans une logique de compétition
victimaire qui est probablement pas la
plus saine du monde pour aborder ces
enjeux là que me fait me la catalogne
maintenant ça y est il ya un radar et
robert qui vient d'être lancée contre
carlès plus demain on verra ce que ça
donne les neuf indépendantistes catalans
qui comparaissaient devant les juges de
la haute cour de justice
à madrid ont eux été placés en détention
provisoire
le ministre des affaires étrangères
espagnol nous a rendu visite ce matin au
figaro il a été interviewé par patrick
st paul rédacteur en chef du service
étranger on le regarde et on parle pour
l'instant les partis catalans qui sont
présentes qui soutiennent l'indépendance
ont décidé on dit qu'il ne participerait
pas mais nous espérons qu'ils vont
changer d'opinion parce que il parle
beaucoup de dialogues mais ils ne
veulent pas venir aux endroits où ce
dialogue peut être conduits dans le
cadre de la constitution espagnole et du
même de ce système d'autonomie plus
largement comment vous qualifier cette
crise c'est une catastrophe pour
l'espagne c'est une crise malheureuse
dont on aurait voulu se passer
et là l'économie commence à subir les
effets ont maintenant on voit à quel
point les mensonges des des catalans
indépendantistes sont réels il disait
que l'économie allait marcher mal
formidablement mais on voit maintenant
que les entreprises et des ménages
alexis vous avez échangé ce matin avec
le ministre espagnol vous l'avez trouvé
comment ça c'est intéressant ce que
quand on parle avec lui et je pense
qu'il se dit que les choses ont basculé
2 de son côté du côté des madrid etc
mais il voit qu'il ya encore un risque
c'est une victimisation des
indépendantistes qui pourrait refaire
éventuellement basculer tout ou partie
de l'opinion des catalans dans le sens
de l'indépendance en les mettant en
détention même s'ils sont fidèles
enfin vous n'avez pas intérêt à les
mettre au trou dit non mais il dit mais
il ya un moment où c'est plus nous c'est
dire qu'à une espèce de logique
judiciaire et pas plus que chez vous vos
politiques ne contrôle vous les juges
bas nous on sait pas trop effectivement
on n'a pas intérêt à ce que à les mettre
tous autres où on a plutôt intérêt à ce
que ça se passe bien et quand je dis
mais finalement couche de mon vous rend
service en partant loin dit je dirais
pas ça comme ça mais au fond ils pensent
que oui il eut le ils ont ils se disent
que maintenant ils ont convoqué des
élections que l'opinion a basculé dans
le sens du du loyalisme de l'unionisme
vise à une madrid mais lui il a pas
l'air de dire que ça va être que le
résultat sera très fort dans une manette
alors ce sera l'heure du nom ce sera 50
3,47 enfin en tout cas il ne crie pas
victoire
mais c'est vrai qu'il ceux qui crachent
c'est le l'épisode de victimisation qui
refuserait encore les choses mais alors
le mandat d'arrêt les dames et le mandat
d'arrêt contre push evans fait beaucoup
non vous avez raison mais alexis vous a
donné la réponse du ministre affaires
étrangères
vous vous savez ce que c'est que l'état
de droit vous savez que les juges
peuvent prendre des décisions qui ne
sont pas conformes forcément aux
desiderata réserve en espagne aurait il
ya écouter d'ailleurs ils ont commencé
quand tribunal constitution annulé le
statut qui donnait plus d'autonomie à 80
gay c'est quand même de l'acsa part
c'est à dire que je sais que c'est moi
je respecte tout le monde fait-il du
tice à l'époque mais je pense qu'on va
aussi le droit de critiquer les
décisions de justice quand elles sont
absurdes ou quand elles sont nées face
mais voilà je pense que la mise en
détention provisoire est une erreur
alors que le coût de d'organiser des
élections est magistrale de la part de
rajoy
et en plus il faut bien comprendre des
élections dans le cadre de l'autonomie
catalane c'est à dire d'un côté avec
l'article 155
il suspend la réalité de l'autonomie en
prenant tous les pouvoirs pour le
pouvoir central
mais en même temps que cela pas du tout
exactement conduiront conserve le cadre
d'autres autonome on change les hommes
voient dans le cadre est présente mais
liu qi
et ça c'est quand même pour le coup
c'est subtil et arriver à être subtil
dans des situations de crises passées de
la sorte il a joué oui pas dire qu'on
ait une impression il ya quelques
semaines au moment de cette
manifestation et augmente cette élection
entre guillemets qui avait dégénéré et
que le pouvoir espagnol était au plus
bas et que il avait commis une erreur
politique absolument majeur c'est ce
qu'on va un peu tout se dit et écrit
vous montrer et puis là il s'avère
qu'avec la tenue de ces élections
effectivement il a complètement repris
la main alors nous on a reçu
l'ambassadeur d'espagne à l'écouter on
va parler tout de suite on essaie
fernando car des réacs qui était ce
matin l'invité de france inter il a la
possibilité de comparaître aujourd'hui
demain ou aujourd'hui et demain drain
de la justice devant des juges qui l'ont
interpellé s'il ne le fait pas la loi se
conclura la loi ce riverain et le jeu je
leur demandais on va faire un mandat
d'arrêt international il y aurait fallu
que je sois quand même un assaut l
ambassadeur à l'étranger qui annonce un
discours musclé que le ministre il a un
discours beaucoup plus musclé que le
ministre quand même beaucoup plus
musclée que que son gouvernement est un
peu c'est un peu étonnant mais lui il
tient le même discours que le mini stade
irf or c'est la loi nous sommes un état
européen de justice est indépendante
on a des lois qu est ce que vous feriez
en france qu'est-ce qui se passera en
italie si effectivement ça serait donc
vous ne pouvez pas ne pas admettre que
nous sommes un état démocratique et
conféré ce prix c'est un peu court quand
même à mon avis il faut comprendre
discours c'est juste un petit peu court
parce que il ya qu'il ya quand même dans
ce processus quelque chose qui a raté
c'est à dire que les autorités
espagnoles un moment donné ont raté un
épisode comment on est passé d'une
situation qui était assez bien maîtrisée
parce qu'ils publient il faut quand même
savoir qu'il ya une réelle autonomie
aujourd'hui dans cette région il ya un
enseignement qui se fait effectivement
dans la langue c'est une province qui
beaucoup plus autonome et qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de droits que n'importe
quelle province française donc et donc
comment peut-on comprendre comment
peut-on comprendre que justement c'est y
ait eu à ce point cette autonomie mais
alors vous allez me dire dans ce que
vous dites c'est dire que quand on a
l'habitude des enfants depuis qu'ils ont
deux ans et demi à parler une langue qui
n'est pas la langue du pays aux
questions sans appartenir au bout d'un
moment ils ne sont plus de ce pays c'est
peut-être pour autant les choses quand
même véritablement beaucoup évolué à
partir de cette décision du tribunal
constitutionnel qui évoquait olivier
c'est à ce moment là que le sentiment
des catalans en faveur d'un état
totalement indépendant s'est mis à
monter et à dépasser et 40%
il se trouve que ça s'est résorbée et
pas depuis la rentrée
et depuis deux ans en fait cette option
là est de moins en moins en ce moment
soutenu par l'opinion catalan est tombé
à 35 % ce qui est peut-être d'ailleurs
pas pour rien dans une forme de
d'accélération de l'attitude
durcissement des amis pendant dix ce
catalan qui avait peut-être le sentiment
qu'une occasion était en train de leur
échapper
et les ce qui caractérise en fait le
vote des catalans c'est que l'étiage des
partis indépendantistes est resté à peu
près stable dans toute cette période
autour de 2 millions un petit peu au
dessus de 40 % en revanche les positions
se sont durcies et toute la question
c'est que va faire l'autre partie du
peuple catalan parce que c'est aussi ça
en fait on n'est pas dans le cas d'un
état qui domine une opinion une
population qui se sentiraient totalement
dépossédés il ya toute cette frange
autour de 60% qui est pour des options
qui vont du statu quo jusqu'à un peu
plus d'autonomie et qui est dans un
sentiment aujourd'hui que les choses ne
sont pas en train de s'arranger et qu'il
est de plus en plus difficile d'être
catalan est exprimé ouvertement ses
histoires et l'astuce qui va consister à
t-on remplacé une élection le référendum
où vous plutôt voter uniquement ceux qui
soutiennent indépendance par une
élection risquerait de ne voter que ceux
qui s'opposent à la dépendance totale va
être peut-être une sorte de pied-de-nez
à c'est assez habile ajoutons juste ça
va de soi mais vaut mieux l'avoir dit on
l'a pas dit qu évidemment en quelques
semaines les dirigeants indépendantistes
à commencer par le premier d'entre eux
se sont ridiculement par des prises de
position je déclare suspens et puis à la
fin de la fièvre il fila à bruxelles
celle de gérard boulanger l'annoncé de
cette mémoire du boulanger jean thissen
correspondance suivie avec nez les
descendeurs du général boulanger qui
vous diront à juste titre que je dors le
boulanger tas d'hommes courageux qui
s'est beaucoup battue qui va débuter sur
les abonnés - la campanie italie la
cochinchine la campagne de kabylie un
homme blessé qui 2 où je ressens
qui donc à se priver de morphine dans à
bout d'un moment d'abattement c'est pour
se défoncer dano sujet alexis le choix
de monsieur puis je demande c'est enfin
c'est pas disneyland et la cua comme
vite mais l'artiste de leur
charismatique qui fait sa conférence de
presse
curieux d'ailleurs ce personnage depuis
le début dont on ne sait pas si c'est le
vrai leader de l'indépendance ou s'il
est porté par des forces qui le
dépassent absolument la fin du
feuilleton où là il va qui finit quand
même par se mettre à l'abri à bruxelles
parce qu'on pourrait penser il donne
envie d'attendre les bêtes je laissais
mon avis tant que rome en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas envie d'aller en
prison
ça paraît absolument clair et donc il
s'est mis à l'abri à bruxelles et c'est
quand même pas et pour les très glorieux
parce que sinon ça va c'est compliqué
bon c'est pas tout ça d'autant plus
compliquée qu'en fait ils sont pas pour
rien qu'ils et elles en belgique c'est
parce qu'il ya un parti autonomiste
flamand qui est très proche des partis
indépendantistes
le catalan qui donc avait un peu
d'ailleurs invité puis demande ce qui
met dans l'embarras le premier ministre
qui est dans la même coalition que ce
parti indépendantiste flamand donc
activement ce n'est pas très commode à
gérer non plus pour les belges et c'est
vrai que ce départ en belgique un côté
bd ou un côté presque alors l'ordre
monsieur l'ambassadeur 17 à votre ville
il n'a pas tout à fait tort d'ailleurs
dans son appréciation
parce que immédiatement on se dit c'est
pas sérieux on se dit ce type n'est pas
sérieux et donc bah voilà on écoute
points on les écoute pas en tout cas
c'est le sentiment je pense pas au point
de vue international que je pense que
dans son propre camp du catalogue c'est
un peu comme ça que je veux c'est sûr
que l'araignée la partie allonnes
ils se seraient emprisonnés tel le
nelson mandela opposant l'allégeance des
principes
enfin il aurait fait beaucoup plus
avancer la cause indépendantiste pas
c'est un vrai de vrai danger y aura un
immense service me semble-t-il à madrid
en fichant le corps à bruxelles nous
avons hugo gagner à nos internautes qui
se demandent si le gouvernement espagnol
le suppose de sous-estimer il pas les
indépendantistes dont les assurés stib
et locales
et d'ailleurs où il ya aussi la question
économique parce qu'il ya la banque
centrale espagnole qui est que la
tension politique sévère et paul ont
prolongé des brochures sur une récession
de l'économie canal du nord en une bonne
partie de la période soit jusqu'en 2019
c'est un démon du tournant quand même
quand les entreprises ont commencé voilà
que l'on trouve dans les écoles les
entreprises et les catalans autonomistes
indépendantistes modérait parce que
c'est un alliage bizarre avec des
gauchistes vraiment le goût de la gauche
de la gauche
et puis des plus tôt des milieux
d'affaires qui sont attachés à leur
dépendance qui en ont marre de payer
pour le sud parce que c'est des
feignants et certains vieillissent pas
c'est partout comme ça et mais cela
quand ils ont vu que l'europe leur
disais vous allez quitter l'europe et
quitter l'euro et les affaires c'est
fini ils ont commencé à changer de camp
des gauchistes irresponsable et des
droites
quand du côté des indépendantistes oui
bien sûr
celui d'avant couche de montrer comment
s'appelait-il à ce mass massol a pas ce
silence sur le cas de monsieur masque
c'est ce soir que seront closes les
candidatures pour le poste de patron de
la république en marche on le sait
christophe castaner désigné par le
président de la république est a priori
seul en course et il prendra la tête des
marcheurs le 18 novembre
le mouvement qui apporte emmanuel macron
à l'elysée doit se transformer en parti
structuré durable mais ce n'est pas une
démobilisation et d'amateurisme à la
république en marche auquel on assiste
depuis quelques semaines on l'entend
dans ses rangs même alors en tout cas
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose j'ai
toujours pas compris comment ça marchait
la république en marche
non mais de manière j'ai regardé j'ai
interrogé quelques députés où quelques
militants on m'a expliqué effectivement
qu'il y avait 700 délégués qu'on allait
élire un conseil de 30 personnes que
dans ce conseil avait j'ai pas tout
compris pour l'instant et puis on voit
surtout que c'est un président de la
république qui nomme lui-même le chef du
parti car il ya quand même un exercice
inhabituel matrix et non mais de fait
dans cette forme dans cette danse est
hyper transparence - on ne cache rien
mais c'est comme si on revendiquait est
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas alors
je sais pas exactement où ça ne
fonctionne pas en tout cas ça fonctionne
pas selon nos logiciels habituels
alors vous allez me dire ah oui mais
justement a compris depuis tout a changé
il n'empêche que dans le fonctionnement
d'un parti c'est aussi une image qu'on a
de la démocratie une façon de faire de
la politique et que là il va falloir
qu'il se passe quelque chose parce
qu'autrement ça devient invisible quoi
heureusement vous avez de la mémoire
parce que qu'ils désignaient les chefs
de les nerfs en général de gaulle était
président qui désignait les chefs de
l'ue dr
kan pourrait tromper nous était
président qui d'adhésine
lionel jospin en 1980 pour être premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui a
désigné françois hollande en 1997 pour
être super beau monde idéal où j'étais
ici ça ne change rien
après il ya eu des petits ratés bien sûr
et on peut espérer que sir martin allons
destin ils auront aussi des petits ratés
mais d'une part il faut pas découvrir la
césarisme nouveau stupéfiante jupiter en
toute sa splendeur et son aura parce que
c'est une constance historique assez
largement et d'autre part peut nier que
le fait que ce soit une constante
historique prouve que le
présidentialisme français dans sa
persistance est plus fort que les
renouveaux participative nouveau monde à
prendre sur le fait du prince
effectivement dont on a déjà parlé mais
sur va en marche
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans comment ils
vont se débrouiller est-ce que ça va
devenir un parti normal que ça marche
pas parce que les partis ne marche pas
tous macro il a gagné contre les parties
à une raconté qu'il ferait un truc qui
serait pas un parti mais finalement
quand on est au pouvoir comme des gens
qui vous soutiennent et qui vont des
députés et puis des militants ça
s'appelle un parti on peut inventer tout
ce qu'on veut c'est reparti or
aujourd'hui on le voit il ya une crise
de la représentation partisane de en
marche des républicains des socialistes
n'en parlons pas et de tous puisque le
bon sens mais aujourd'hui que le
militantisme en fait tout s'est tu ces
mécanismes de qui avait depuis des
siècles ou plus d'un siècle en tout cas
en france
deux représentations politiques de parc
et par capillarité pyramide ça ne
fonctionne pas les gens s'y
reconnaissent plus les gens s'expriment
différemment et s'exprime par les
sondages et expriment par d mais bon est
donc en marche finalement n'est pas
épargné par le diagnostic que que mâcon
avait forte à l'encontre de tous les
partis et ces deux mareyeurs en marche
pour en fait marche a très bien marché
ce a couru mais c'est une structure a
d'abord eu donc à les invectiver
c'était deux et c'est ça qui motivait
les gens il faut il faut que pour que
les gens participent à une structure
comme un parti politique ou une autre
forme d'engagement politique il faut
qu'ils aient un retour sur
investissement le retour sur
investissement c'était la jouissance de
participer à une aventure réussie et
j'essaie de l'histoire s'est écrite
jusqu'au bout de belle manière pour
légende en marche comment on passe d'une
structure ad-hoc à une structure qui va
de manière pérenne
exister localement 25 pieds ce qui quand
même est un élément fort de retour sur
investissement pour les militants qui
sont le fait de punir des fonctions soit
au sein d'un parti soient les fonctions
électives
or en marche n'a aucun poste a distribué
jusqu'en 2020 à part bien peut-être une
quinzaine de sièges de député européen
donc c'est aussi un des problèmes de la
partie qui manque d'une structure de
représentation et qui est condamné
effectivement à une réinvention parce
qu'il ya cette crise qu'elle ait
qu'alexi décrivait de leur présentation
partisanes traditionnelles
je pense que là on est vraiment un
moment charnière pour en marche il
n'empêche que même si j'ai entendu ce
que vous disiez certes ça s'inscrit dans
une très longue tradition politique
française mais justement moi j'avais cru
comprendre que emmanuel macron avait
s'élever contre cette manière de faire
de la politique
de surcroît la façon dont il a bâti son
mouvement en marche c'était totalement
atypique forcément parce que c'était
nouveau
mais en fait il s'agissait pour lui de
changer tous les critères de faire autre
chose de faire différemment et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve en réalité en
tout cas pour la désignation parce que
il faut parler désignation plus que
d'élection du responsable du parti avec
la plus vieille façon la plus classique
la plus traditionnelle face au cra de la
politique donc c'est là à mon avis où il
ya un décalage entre le discours qu'ont
apporté et puis ce qui se passe dans la
réalité une fois que vous avez
absolument raison et dans les ouvrages
on a eu la gentillesse de cité en début
d'émission sur des très sévères sur la
structure le mode de fonctionnement
maintenant ce qui est frappant c'est que
l'observateur a publié à trois semaines
des extraits du livre de jacques
julliard l'esprit du peuple dans lequel
il parle avec une façon très pertinente
sur cette disparition du modèle qui a
été si prévenant être particulièrement à
gauche d'un parti invaincu avec adhésion
prise de quatre réunions régulières des
cellules militantisme assidus élections
des dirigeants souveraineté solennité du
congrès etc
donc ça a disparu et c'est ce qui
affecte ses les grands partis maintenant
on est dans un moment très difficile où
il faut inventer quelque chose de
nouveau on peut par exemple pas laisser
dans le vie
vous avez besoin de structurer les
candidatures vous avez besoin qui est
des choses qui arrivent du bas vers le
haut et du haut vers le bas vous avez
besoin que si recul la confrontation
d'idées vous acceptez vous avez besoin
que les élus soient soutenu écouté
entendu et ses textes à ce qui est
frappant c'est que les deux mouvements
nouveaux qui sont en marge d'un côté et
la france sera soumise au vote
aujourd'hui sur des mouvements
premièrement pour repris des termes crus
totalement bordélique et deuxièmement
totalement sert à rien c'est à dire
totalement soumis directement au chef
c'est le désordre régulée dans le cher
la dictature oui c'est ça ce qui est
quand même et évidemment pas
satisfaisant mais c'est quand même assez
frappant que les deux seules soit disons
à ce stade primitif de l'invention de
trop tôt parti qui va bien falloir créer
sur un mode nouveau ou faisait quand
même une autre faction de fonctionner
mais des choses à faire
christophe castaner d'un bateau et le
bonhomme à la bonne place ils ont cumulé
- il est moins dangereux en tout cas
pour macron que son rival qui avait
divisé sur paris voilà que ça peut être
vraiment d'explication d'homme en outre
être agnostique lui aussi donc il a sans
doute plus d'expérience jusqu'alors de
ces questions d'appareil déquilibre
puisque c'est un élu local
je suis grand chef il faut que je trouve
quelqu'un soit relativement bon mais qui
viennent pas me faire de l'ombre et me
concurrencer directement
donc je vais pas mettre en bière il
s'est plutôt d'accord je vais pas m beau
jeu de mettre la mer avec cette réserve
qui est que christophe castaner est
encore un inconnu pour la plupart des
français donc il va primer alors ça va
venir ou pas parce que outre l'imparfait
du subjonctif
je salue ce que nous enseigne
ok c'est que être présidents de partis
nat n'offre pas la même plus value en
termes de notoriété de visibilité que ce
que c'était le cas il ya encore dix ou
quinze ans comme peuvent en témoigner
rester porte parole et il n'avait pas de
là il avait pas un personnage doté de
mortalité en magasin c'est ça le
problème aussi ne l'avait pas je me
contente de dire quel est l'apport de
monsieur castaner à la réplique sera
question annexe
ça paraît normal qu'ils restent au
gouvernement pas castaner alors là
encore si on suit ça c'est en service
pendant des siècles non seulement
c'était tout le rythme et s'était même
exigé les les patrons des parties
devaient être au gouvernement sinon ça
n'avait pas de sens et dessins pour
toute la 4e et même beaucoup sous la
vème alors on peut dire que maintenant
les temps ont changé enfin s'il est que
pas trop dommage c'est qu'on dit que
finalement les parties dès aujourd'hui
ne servent plus à grand chose entre deux
élections présidentielles parce que
c'est ça qu'on est en train de voir
on est passé des parts est une vieille
histoire on est parti du passé 2010
parti de militants en partie de
supporteurs qui existe à fond à fond
dans le xvième présidentielle n'a pas
signé entre les deux il faut une
structure partisane et technocratique
pour distribuer des investitures la
vérité quand même c'est que les français
s'en foutent totalement
on est d'accord qui reste ou pas au
gouvernement comme dirait emmanuel
rivière comme ils connaissent pas ça
leur est égal
hugo ne s'en fiche pas lui il dit c'est
un parti vite sans cadre macro attendait
l'afflux de cadres et l'eire qui sont
restés fidèles à leur famille sans cet
afflux j'imagine la république en marche
trés tombera dans l'oubli dans cinq ans
qu'ils descendent c'est un interview à
l'internaute s'appelle hugo emmanuel
rivière vous avez fait un sondage sur la
popularité des manuels macron popularité
figaro magazine tout à fait popularité
qui continuent de baisser légèrement il
à faire du donc au total c'est le
combien 19 depuis hier six mois 19.19
points 38% donc on va dire que c'est
stable par rapport à mois dernier un
point de perdu et de lecture de cette de
cette évolution le niveau est assez bas
et comparable celui de françois hollande
il ya cinq ans ce qui est intéressant
parce que il ya françois hollande ya
cinq ans commenté déjà les grandes
difficultés dans lesquelles il se
trouvait alors qu'on estime aujourd'hui
qui manuel macron tire bien son épingle
d'un jeu compliqué c'est pas totalement
faux de dire que ne pas chuter entre le
mois de septembre et le mois d'octobre
peut-être considérée comme une réussite
compte tenu des nuages et salmi du
contexte des socialistes un cloud qu'il
fallait franchir
attention regardez cinq derniers
présidents de la vème république il y en
avait trois
jacques chirac en 95 françois hollande
en 2012
emmanuel macron qui a six mois de leur
accession à l'elysée se retrouvent dans
les niveaux bas autour de 38 36%
puis nicolas sarkozy au dessus de 50%
françois mitterrand à 60%
donc il ya un décrochage quand même des
manuels macron par rapport à certains de
ses prédécesseurs
la taxe sur les dividendes le nouveau
feuilleton ça peut être une repin pour
emmanuel macron on n'a pas fait un sujet
en soi mais c'est quand même compliqué
il était à bercy et au moment où doivent
donc il n'est pas complètement exempt de
tout reproche dans cette affaire les
deux choses d'abord le casse tête que
c'est le cas cette budgétaire parce que
10 milliards ça se trouve pas sous le
pas d'un cheval même si on en reprend 5
milliards aux entreprises
encore faut-il que la nouvelle taxe
qu'on va appliquer votre vie ce ne soit
pas elle aussi à son tour à
constitutionnel mais bon c'est
énormément d'argent qu'il faut trouver
parce que sinon ça veut dire que les
déficits vont déraper a donc il ya un
problème technique de budget qui est
extrêmement compliqué à résoudre
après quant à l'origine et à la cause de
cette taxe qui est elle-même été dessiné
ces chinois qui était destiné à
remplacer une autre taxi avait été
écarté et pascal constitutionnel ben oui
macron il a été associé puisqu'à
l'époque qui devait traiter
l'elysée comme toute la question
ce qui est drôle c'est que le maire a
annoncé une enquête pour savoir d'où
venait ce scandale d'état
enquête qui va être confiée à
l'inspection des finances qui avait
enquêté sur les inspecteurs des finances
dont emmanuel maubert ici ça
m'étonnerait qu'on arrive à quelque
chose d'absolument faramineux vous y
croyez à cette enquête
je suis en train de penser que sa mère
quand même accroché dans sa voix tout
cas on peut ajouter que le conséquent
seul y est allé fort quand même parce
que une chose est de déclarer
inconstitutionnelle cette taxe mais le
no 4 qui dès qu'elle a appris que la
côte on peut s'appliquer
il faut alors qu'ils auraient pu très
bien dire que c'était pour l'avenir et
pas glisser fameux 10 milliards qui sont
très difficiles à trouver
ces mêmes c'est même assez étonnant que
conséquence d'être une décision aussi
grave pour ne pas dire et responsables
dont dix ans pour ne pas dire je me
protège bon la dérision mais c'est du je
pense probablement à l'extraordinaire
technicité du sujet d'une part et peu de
tête de la part de laurent fabius un
certain goût d'impuissance de son
institution peut-être sait-on jamais le
verdict dans la sphère du dans le procès
verra est imminent me dit on on va
parler de la légion d'honneur fini les
eaux chez napoléon disait que c'est avec
des hochets qu'on mène les hommes
emmanuel macron veut-il les supprimer
pour mieux les mettre en marche en tout
cas il entend accorder moins
généreusement la légion d'honneur le
figaro en a fait sa une ce matin
christophe castaner qui dit à l'issue du
conseil des ministres qui avaient le ce
matin on n'aura plus la légion d'honneur
à l'usure ou par copinage
c'est une réforme qui ne coûte rien et
qui populaire coup double pour emmanuel
macron de man uvre eh bien je pense que
ça fera écho effectivement avec un
sentiment
de la part des français qui a vu une
facilité de distribution dans l'autre
soit de ces distinctions qui faisait pas
forcément chance pour eux les français
pouvaient se trouver tout à fait
souhaitable normale et est remarquable
ce n'était pas tant sur des parcelles
avec quelle phrase serait la plus
efficace et pour qu'on attribue ces
distinctions à des gens qui font des
choses qui sauvent des vies des gens qui
ont des exploits sportifs qui sont des
grands inventeurs et c est donc plus de
mal à l'accorder à ces gens qui font de
très belles carrières qui accomplissent
des choses dans leur domaine mais dont
beaucoup de français particulièrement
fâché quand on se compare avec nos
voisins européens avec leurs élites
on pense on tendance à penser que c'est
surtout leur carrière qu'ils ont servi
et qui joue ainsi récompensé
effectivement pour une forme de
proximité avec le pouvoir
donc oui symboliquement ça peut avoir
sur le moment un petit effet mais dans
un mois tout le monde aura oublié
c'est effectivement la question du jour
du figaro qui la question était pensez
vous que l'on accorde trop facilement la
légion de la légion d'honneur la réponse
est oui à 98%
merouane azzi de ce qui attend d'excusés
donc ils seront difficilement à la soie
il faut facilement aux autres alors
merouane m'a dit bonjour vous nous
rejoignez pour nous dire ce que ce qui
se dit sur les réseaux sociaux sur cette
grave question de la légion d'honneur
et oui et donc là c'est la première fois
que je vois 98% à la question du jour
sur le flanc
du coup j'ai posé la même question sur
twitter et la même constat un peu moins
89 % de oui qui accorde une fin qui
pensent que la légion d'honneur est
accordé trop facilement et donc on a
ne riez pas au nom des internautes ce
soir poulet 1959 qui nous dit sur
twitter
ils ont tellement donné à n'importe qui
que plus personne n'est curieux de
savoir quel genre de service qu'ils ont
pu rendre à la nation
on a simple citoyen 001 qui est d'accord
avec le journaliste bruno masure qui
s'insurgeait sur twitter il faut arrêter
la distribuer à tout va la légion
d'honneur c'est comme le bac on le donne
même sans en avoir la moyenne
antoine pas du bac on en parle quand
même on a dit nan elbakin est contente
qu à moitié nous dit pour une fois je
suis d'accord avec macron mais dommage
que lui réussissent à la voir sans grand
mérite au mna michel demain un autre t
elle assez un témoignage cette fois que
nous dit j'ai enterré mon oncle un
ancien de la 2e division blindée et
oubliés de la légion il a libéré paris
les anciens combattants de bretagne
n'ont pas demandé cette décoration
bravo à ce président et enfin je vais
termine avec blague à part qui nous dit
cela va être long et difficile de lui
redonner de la valeur au vu de sa
réputation
peut-être vaut-il mieux en inventer une
nouvelle pour distinguer les vrais héros
civile est ce qu'on la donne n'importe
qui la légion d'honneur
c'est souvent ce que le 10 des
internautes en paix s'est pas trompé
mano ne manqueront pas ce que c'est
exactement ce que vous disiez ça coûte
pas cher comme ma forme et on sait que
c'est pour le moins populaire
en tout cas on sort sur une forme de
populisme on pourrait presque aller
jusque là même si elle est profond des
choses effectivement à revoir dans les
processus d'obtention de la légion
d'honneur
mais ça prouve là son côté il fait
différemment de la politique
il n'oublie pas de bons réflexes pour
savoir ce qui flatte l'opinion en tout
cas
parler des promotions de la légion
d'honneur et leur donner quelques
chiffres ce matin confie dookie à 20000
légion d'honneur distribués sur 4 ans et
10 mois parce que c'est là il faut
compter le recordman et en alors c'est
difficile hier basse et françois
mitterrand vient forcément avec pour moi
c'est énorme et en moyens il est très
régulier c'est fort on voit que sarkozy
ont donné trois mille quatre cents soit
une par an mitterrand 3452 hall 1 3444
et chaque 3440 donc c'était extrême en
or mais en fait c'était pas bon
s'appuyèrent magro est en train de
diviser par trois ans à la bête plutôt
pour la thèse de ma couille parce que ça
devient dire que je souhaitais pas les
actes d'heure ou de service de la nation
qui étaient partis flamands de rémy qui
avait une sorte d'automatisme pour mais
avait décollé par exemple forme des gens
m'ont dit mais comment tu n'as pas
légion d'honneur d'inventaire à 22h pour
faits de résistance donc j'étais un peu
gêné moi l idée de j'ai pas fait des
choses extraordinaires mais mais mais
voilà donc dans la norme de notre
société
je devais avoir les jeûneurs et
d'ailleurs j'ai dû dire deux fois que je
trouvais qu'il y avait pas de raison de
me la donner parce que c'est la mort eh
ben ça c'est pas normal que ce soit
devenu une norme c'est ce que dit
flaubert d'un dictionnaire des idées
reçues je cite l'édito d'étienne de
montety la blague aimé la convoitée
quand on l'obtient toujours dire qu'on
n'a pas demandé
il faut la retirer ou
notamment aux étrangers par l on a parlé
récemment de la ferraille stein savoir
s'il fallait lui retirait ses genre de
polémique un peu vaine ou d'annoncés
codifie vous savez il ya des cas où le
retrait est automatique sur certains
types de condamnations en national c'est
plus simple donc on imagine par exemple
avec un peu délicat que maurice papon
concerne sa légion d'honneur pour
prendre un exemple d'une personne avec
laquelle on ne souhaitait pas forcément
là partagé par milo ensuite c'est à la
fois c'est comme toutes choses égales
par ailleurs c'est comme si on disait en
début d'émission sur le procès verra
c'est pas l'opinion qui doit donner
enlevé légion d'honneur à un moment
donné on a failli donner légion
d'honneur à titre posthume aux victimes
du bataclan et le grand chancelier de la
légion d'honneur à l'étoile que général
georgelin a d'écouter les gens d'honneur
c'est pas fait pour donner à des
victimes et il a fallu qu'il ait fait
l'a été donné à titre posthume aux
victimes de charlie hebdo et de l'hyper
cacher me semble-t-il n'est pas au
bataclan alors là aussi on peut dire il
va peut-être un peu de poids deux
mesures parce que ce qui a des bonnes et
mauvaises entre guillemets bonnes et
mauvaises victimes c'est compliqué mais
c'était le côté effectivement disons oui
pour les paires cacher vous auriez
raison mais sur le char l'immuno disons
que ces gens qui étaient dans leur
dessin et dans leurs fonctions en
première ligne dans la résistance à une
certaine forme de dogmatisme et pas des
gens victimes par hasard c'est ça la
différence
quelle est la petite vous allez sans
doute tous répondent qu'elle est la
devise de la légion d'honneur patrice
c'est un honneur et patrie me voilà une
belle découverte je sais pas si on a des
images mais de la pyramide de khéops un
immense espace de vide qui intrigue
beaucoup les scientifiques
ça a été annoncé aujourd'hui avec
le figaro magazine en avait déjà parlé
avec un procédé scientifiquement mais
tous et totalement alexis on met des
plaques
c'est la technique du ganglion seniors
millions muse ne dis pas ça pour les
diédhiou met donc c'est le million est
une particule astuces notre la taille de
l'espace et qui ont la particularité
pour des particules d'être plus ou moins
absorbés par les matériaux qu'elle
rencontre sur leur chemin donc on met
des plaques photographiques dans un
endroit de la pyramide et selon qu'ils
reçoivent plus ou moins bien pendant des
jours et des jours plus ou moins 2
millions on en déduit que oui ou non il
ya d une dalle et où une épaisseur au
dessus et donc on peut en déduire qu'il
ya une cavité donc créé une immense
qualité n'est pas me laisser cette
émission c'est pas le jeu c'est possible
qu'il y en a qui sont regardables qui
sont un peu
ma mère de printemps sur la partie c'est
lui qui a découvert cet espace est
français ou pas mais il ya débat il ya
des japonais il ya des anglais du jem il
ya des tas de toute la question est là
donc c'est pas totalement truquée non
plus avait souligné que les structures
pyramidales finalement le fonctionner qu
aujourd'hui il avait une dans sa botte
et l'ouvrir et bien je vous remercie
tous les quatre merci à vous tous et on
se retrouve demain pour un nouveau point
de vue présentée par guillaume roquette
[Musique]